Cuba's former revolutionary leader Fidel
Castro has died he was 90 years old his
brother and successor President Raul
Castro announced his death on Cuban
state television Friday evening Fidel
was best known as a communist dictator
and remained at odds with the United
States of America many Cubans world
leaders and celebs across the nation
reacted to the news on Saturday
president-elect Donald Trump released a
statement that read today the world
marks the passing of a brutal dictator
who oppressed his own people for nearly
six decades President Obama offered
condolences to Fidel's family and wrote
the Cuban people must know that they
have a friend and partner in the United
States of America Cuban American
musician Emilio Estefan pinned an
emotional message to those who died
under Castro's regime writing we thank
you and honor you for fighting for
freedom and human rights for our
homeland your sacrifice will never be
forgotten
today there is a new dawn filled with
hope for our beloved Cuba his wife
Gloria shared the same sentiments
writing on Instagram although the death
of a human being is rarely cause for
celebration
it is the symbolic death of the
destructive ideologies that he espoused
that I believe is filling the Cuban
exile community with renewed hope and a
relief that has been long in coming